okay hello and welcome so this is one of
the more advanced crash courses if you
are just working on the fundamentals of
the language I would encourage you to
tune out possibly even move further away
where I'm not going to accidentally be
pointing and falling at you all are
probably doing it the idea here is we
want to give you the kind of fifteen
minute overview of the essentials you
need to know in order to participate in
writing backbone apps and reading
backbone code and understanding what's
going on and then you'll have about 15
minutes to work whatever projects you
are already kind of like dabbling in and
our TAS can circulate that support if
you're not going to be listening to the
backbone crash course and you're going
to be instead working on the curriculum
that's provided for the main line
fundamentals work the TAS will support
you for that too feel free to just flag
one down as a reminder as if there are
so many people here you know who haven't
been to some of the previous lectures
since it's more advanced I just like to
give you a quick heads-up about the
format of this class point number one
it's highly interactive and when I call
on you the intent not to kind of like
screw up your day the intent is to check
myself to see how well I've done
communication concept and if you've been
here already you know that the following
is true you will be shocked at how
difficult it is for you and the people
around you to simply reiterate sentences
I've just said that turns out to be
extremely difficult tracking on what a
speaker
has to say is so difficult in fact that
I have learned to to demilitarize if you
will the idea of not knowing the answer
and being called upon and all of the
embarrassment that could be accompanied
with that we kind of try to throw that
out the window in this format so be
ready to be called on and know that when
you don't understand the answer and
barely understand the question
you are very representative of everyone
else in the room and it's okay it's the
only way I can do a good job in doing so
the second point that I'd like to know
is that it's very important that you be
actually making something or doing
something with the information we
provide that's why we have all these TAS
here this week is so that we can
actually work with you on your actual
problems if if you stick around you can
work on some of the fundamental
materials those are the curriculum for
that is findable act J has come to 2014
da hack reactor comm you'll find some
curriculum there at a github repo you
can download it and start working
through the assignments and the TAS will
circulate some of them needs a bit more
sort of personal instruction and it's a
much of it is supported by these
lectures so to take a brief diversion
into this advanced crash course I'm
going to tell you not this is not
advanced for people who already know
backbone this is advanced for people
just learning JavaScript the following
talk is going to be very fast
introduction to a framework but it will
not have much pertinent information to
you who are already writing the backbone
no makes sense
okay so to get things kicked off can I
get a show of hands of people who are in
the room because of the fundamental
curriculum and that
they plan to keep working on through the
top a little bit and can I get a so
handsome people who are in the room
because they want to hear the short
version of how to write backbone okay so
with that in mind I'm gonna start
calling people up some people are random
if I accidentally mistake you as being
if the backbone crew just correct me
tell me you district probably to the
downside so what I want to know is where
you're starting what you're doing the
backbone so that I can make sure that
I'm speaking to your actual experience
at your use case can I get a sense of
what what you do with back though or
don't do with backbone or wire quite
just comes assess it no experience in
perfect okay that's uh that's very
helpful no experience in backbone
moderate experience of JavaScript
experience back encounter knows
JavaScript well never trust backbone
wants to wants to speak to the
development workflow that the front-end
guys are using with an informal sense
and as a calibration mechanism for me
when you say you know JavaScript well
what does the object that create
function do a new instance of a blank
object close enough yeah that's the 80
80 percent answered a lot of subtle
difference object uh create generates a
new object that does property delegation
to the Infinity I think you know okay
sweet and one more you there with me
sort of plaid like shirt
what do you where's your backbone
situation I do
to get a more broad picture
architectural solutions and touch back
on the living existence
it's got it so play the little backbone
code when you encounter it how to get
mini apps from scratch consulting
experience experience of JavaScript it
sounds like okay cool well then what
we're about what we have planned is
pretty well targeted at what it seems as
though you guys think so what I'm going
to do is I'm the breaking man on some of
the lingo of jump of a backbone I'm
going to show you the keywords and I
don't need keywords in the JavaScript
keyword except I mean the word that you
are going to see when you're writing or
reading backbone code that have special
meaning to the backbone librarian to the
backbone community or whatever reason
the significance of these words is
pretty desperately documented you don't
find in my experience a central you know
list of what it is you need to have
heard of and how you need to interpret
certain words but the backbone library
will treat these words great like it
super special ways although
documentation exists for each of these
words that you will find self typing in
a backbone out they don't seem to just
be consolidated in one kind of like
glossary that's kind of how I'm
approaching they tell you the terms and
as I tell you the terms I'm going to
kind of like paint a picture of why you
might use this
and how a special meaning one of the
backbone tenants that seems to silently
guide how the framework was written is
that the key words we're going to see
the key terms that we're going to see
here are assumes to have inherent
meaning to the to the developers of the
framework about the workflow of writing
eleven initializes a great example
you've probably if you've seen any
backbone code you've seen the word
initialize pop up here and there you may
or may not realize that that that
anything stored at the key initialized
is likely to be treated very specialty
by backbone when backbone interact with
the objects that you build append to it
and it sees something at the key
initialized it does something very
interesting and it's somewhat assumed
that you are going to Intuit the
significance of special words and that
you are also going to into it which
words you should use to express ideas
you already have in your mind my goal
here is to connect ideas are already
familiar with with words you've probably
seen and kind of make it clear that
seeing those words means something
special in this language so first of all
the types of words you will see whenever
you're interacting with a constructor
backbone top model is one of the primary
constructors the backbone provides it
allows you to build one of the three
pillars of the MVC architecture the
backbone is trying to support if you're
not super familiar with MVC here's the
new sentence version MVC architecture
claims that you can divide your
application into at least three distinct
parts and then in so doing the code that
you find in any one of those parts
should look very homogeneous as
so the rest of the code you will bind
there it will all have a similar
character and there won't be a lot of
conflicting or disparate goals in one in
once I love one of these three Cylons
it'll all be about the same goal it's
generally good practice in software
engineering to separate your concerns
and that's the intent of MVC each of
these terms refers to different aspects
of the application and they are
interpreted somewhat differently from
from Architecture from Franklin
framework I'll offer you my most general
version model represents the data and
rules about how we get to manipulate
that data view represents what is seen
by the user and there's a major
disconnect between those two right model
and model and view to feel as different
as truth and perception it's clearly a
big difference between truth and
perception there's only one truth it's
out there to be measured and observed
but it doesn't change whereas perception
varies from person to person and can be
mistaken and is a bit of a bit of a
transformation on truth the same is true
of models and views there may be many
views that all represent a single model
that represent a single piece of data
but that one piece of data is where we
will hold the rules governing how it
could change over time
lastly controller the notion of a
controller is not particularly used in
JavaScript but in general it means the
thing that manages user in that is the
most general definition I can find or
think of for controller luckily we're
not going to have to dig into that too
much to understand
so let's just focus on model and view
before I go mom I would like to make
sure that you guys feel comfortable with
the premise of backbone and the intent
of an MVC architecture well enough that
it will start to make sense how and how
backbone is solving those problems for
you how comfortable you guys feel to
trying to defend the MVC architecture
through a room full of people if you
were called upon thumbs up that would be
easy for me thumbs down you only said it
once this is terrifying
thumbs middle I've kind of heard of it
for a long time so I feel like maybe I
could take a step could you take a stab
at it with the hat there
yep that's great and how would you just
how would you distinguish what models
are versus what views are ignoring
completely controlling from great
the model being the Vita the the data
and the viewing the presentation let me
tweak the first one model is not only
the data but also the rules that govern
how that data can change those are the
methods to get attached to in an
object-oriented sense the methods that
govern the internal consistency of any
one object and how it can interact with
other objects great so basically
programs you've written that have no
user interface programs that like do
simulations physics simulations would
not necessarily need any presentation
and so all of the object-oriented
principles can work quite well because
it's just in a computer it's just truth
kind of colliding with other truth right
as soon as you try to present that to a
user you have to distort truth substance
fits on a computer screen
sometimes you duplicate the way that
you're presenting a big deal you'll
you'll present a single fact twice the
number of unread messages is seven you
show that in several different ways
there's an unread count in the upper
right corner and there's a number of
messages that you can see and then
there's like one next to your inbox
there's all these places that the same
fact shows up that is not true about
models models try to consolidate serves
in one spot and these have all of these
different rules so that is my crash
crash crash course in MVC so that we can
start to understand what backbones try
to Opera's backbone model is a
constructor that will allow us to create
these objects to encapsulate truth and
behavior around a given entity in our
system so if we have a user we might
want a back-up model to represent that
user backbone dot view is a constructor
to generate the projection into user
visible space of that model and then
back though duck collection is more is
very
similar to a backbone model a backbone
that collection an instance of a
backbone a collection is intended to be
sort of an array like structure that
could contain many backbone mobs ideally
backbone that collection would have been
a subclass of backbone model in much the
same way that JavaScript arrays are a
subclass of JavaScript objects but
unfortunately they did not make this
design choice when they wrote the
framework and so a lot of the things
that you come to value about models
won't be true collections even though
intuitively you might think that they
ought to be I personally agree that they
ought to be if that's how you feel but
we live in this world instead of you
when you are interacting with these
constructors you may choose to subclass
them and in fact you will have to the
subclass them pretty quickly if you're
going to make an application with models
and with views you're probably going to
customize the generic model on the
generic view to be useful in your
application as soon as you decide you
need something other than the very
vanilla backbone model instance or
backbone view instance and heads up
you'll basically never one of the
militarism of those you immediately need
to subclass them and start specifying
how your models are interested or how
your views are interested perhaps you
know an instantiation pattern in
JavaScript like functional instantiation
or perhaps you know pseudo-classical
instantiation usually keyword new and
setting the dot prototype property on
your constructor function that sets etc
if you do know those things bully for
you you have to sort of ignore that
pattern whatever pattern you know
or patterns and you have used a new
pattern of defining a constructor the
backbone is created for you with the
hopes of simplifying your process of
writing a constructor and writing the
class if you want to make a new class
you're going to say backbone model die
extend you'll pass in a hash that kind
of helps specify what your class should
behave like and it'll return you and a
new class if this is a little confusing
right
the extend function seems to be a
factory that produces classes that
that's reasonable we are calling a
function that returns a class so that we
can use that class to create instances
thumbs up whether you've explained to me
what I mean when I say backbone down
extend is a factory that produces
classes that produces instances
okay so that means we need to go over a
little more so backbone has eschewed the
traditional instantiation and sub
classing systems that you use in
JavaScript you're likely to be using the
pseudo-classical pattern it's okay if
you ever heard that word is the one
that's documented all over the internet
doctor over time you were do you know
keyword this all sorts of stuff like
everything you've read about
instantiations that subclassing is
probably about the student class of a
pattern there is a much simpler
alternative called functional that
nobody uses except a few super lead
people you can use that either backbone
says you must use our system for
generating classes you don't get to
write them out manually you just tell
backbone about your class and it
generates it for you the way that you
tell backbone advisor class is by
calling a function so imagine for a
moment that I was going to start
building factories I want a car factory
so I start putting bricks on top of
bricks and I install this big piece of
machinery and I sort of like conveyor
belt for the for the line and hooks to
carry things around and I'm done with my
factory and out to build cars there's
one fact to me let me go over here mind
you this is a complicated process
building and building a factory in
JavaScript building your class is easy
to screw up so I made one and I'm doing
good and then I decide to make a second
factory I go over here and I start
stacking bricks on top of bricks and I
put other machinery this above factory
over here I finished building my boat
Factory and I'm like wow I am tired I
wish I could just do something call some
high level function and have it produced
factories right that is what backbone is
trying to give you with this dive
extending the die extend
function the not extend method of
backbone model is a generator that
generates classes in much the same way
as if I had a magical box but when I
press
but out popped a brand-new factory I'd
say top has wheels and it goes fluff and
it makes a factory can produce cars I go
boat it's funny and top out comes
another factory that's a pretty fair
analogy for the dye extended you'll find
on all backbone classes when you make
the backbone class using that extend it
reduces a class that also has died
extend on the classic produces is a
subclass of whatever you were not
extending if you say back on that model
that extend you get subclass of backbone
up mama so maybe you say var user equals
backbone up mom let extent if you
specify something about how it works and
all of a sudden the user variable stores
a class you can now say far super user
equals user not extend and pass in some
specifications there so my point is you
want to think about backbone classes
you'll notice that they have capitalized
letters like em for Model D C and that's
a different scene in MVC
when you see those that's what you know
you can use that extent when you build a
subclass you can use that extend there
as well any questions about the story of
you trading subclasses of the primitive
backbone classes or subclasses of your
own sometimes I feel as though the
better beings one question pretty
confident so I'm curious if anybody has
a question for that extent what go great
we're going to cover that next but what
goes into extend is a fantastic question
fine
oh yes how do we use this extent
function perfectly reasonable that's the
next the next slide but I don't mean to
I don't mean to stop the questions are
there any are there any others the
initiation story is the same as regular
JavaScript pseudo-classical
instantiation you just say new and then
the classic cool okay so I said that you
were going to tell this dot extend
method looking on your class to be like
all constructors expect you to pass in a
parameter that's going to look like two
curly braces in between physics these
parentheses those curly braces to find
an object and that object specifies what
your class is supposed to be like I'm
going to go into what kinds of
properties we put on that objects it
even specify a class in the next slide
the point is you must pass the params
hash into this die extent in order to
generate anything meaningful using die
extent that's the one argument that a
that die extends expect a list of make a
collection of key value pairs that
explain the backbone what your new class
should be like
does that make sense kind of like when I
whispered it's floating over to my a
special machine we got to offer some
input the form of the input is a
princess so starting to talk about what
goes into that params hash the the most
important in most cases the most
important special property is
initialized initialized
is the key that you will use to talk
about some function that should be run
on every new instance I'm going to do a
quick code example
so in backbone I might say bar user
equals I'll read this okay
by our user equal backbone top model dot
extend
and inside here so my params hats just
to be clear is this thing and inside
here I would like to specify what my
class is supposed to be like I'm going
to say initialize because this is
perhaps the most important thing to
specify I am now typing out the code
that should be run whenever a new
instance of this class gets made so I
might say for example this dot location
sorry this dot what use it have age this
dot age equals default aides could be
zero
later the user could set the age right
or let's say let's say this dot profile
pic equals random avatar so in this
example every new user instance is going
to get a random picture as their avatar
for as long as the application is
running
what does the initialize function do yes
but what weeks yes whenever you create
an instance of the class this code will
run on the brand new instance does that
mean that the highlighted function is in
fact the constructor sorry I know the
line if I may take a brief moment to
explain miles integers is now there is
an illusion that we all suffer from in
classes where it appears as though
everyone understands stuff better than
us but it tends to be the case that
that's just because you only talk when
you know the answer and so looking
around you'll see a lot of people are
not confused by whatever you're confused
about but in fact they are they just
didn't happen to be talking them so I
try to I try to avoid that by only
talking to people that I select on a
random basis no that's a little bit
follow that so does that mean that this
is this function is the constructor
it's up that's a great way to say he
said either this highlighting function
is the constructor itself or the
constructor is going to call this
function so in fact just for your
edification backbone generates a new
constructor function that is not the
highlighted function and that new
constructor function will run this on
every new instance so slight
disambiguation and in practice you're
not going to notice a difference you're
going to write this an essay
the constructor function that gets
returned and the capital you user is
going to hold
but that extent method returns some
function that doesn't happen to be the
highlighted one but the return function
will call a highlighted does that make
sense yes you go to stack if you were to
extend this one both initialize good
question
if we subclass user to make super user
will the subclass automatically call the
superclass instantiated of the
superclass initialized the answer is no
unfortunately you have to specify that
manually you could argue that it's
preferable if you have to specify it
manually if you're written in Python to
each other so in Ruby it's not super but
there's some way that you call the super
version of a bath right here there was
monkey-patching a long time then they
replaced that with somebody comes ok so
the requirement that you call your
superclass initializer in backbone is
analogous to the fact that in Ruby you
probably have to call stupid and you
would prefer to be able to specify when
and where that super call happens so you
can do something that's analogous to
super here it's not a keyword that lets
you unfortunately
javascript does not make it possible
certainly not easy and I would argue not
possible to implement super light
behavior that is actually consistent
I've seen a lot of people make very
valiant attempts but I've never seen a
version of super that works as expected
in all cases so no unfortunately the
framework developers didn't put around
unfortunately they did not attempt to
give you as who a broken a super feature
instead they just leave it up to you to
say in your in your super user subclass
you to stay to show you in your super
user subclass you would say user dot
line
you're not familiar with this line it's
okay that's what we're going over at
4:00 when you explain exactly what this
craziness is about but again this is the
crash course in backbone so sorry if I
give that particular thing it seems
Stewart so this is pretty much what you
needed to know about constructors in
backbone are there any questions before
we move on to some of the other key
turns things about instructions
radical let's talk about instances so
constructors are like the factories that
produce similar objects that you're
going to be needing a lot of there are
different rules for each of these each
of these things when I am interacting
with a model instance what I expect of a
backbone model instance is that it will
intercede on my my interactions with the
properties of that object for regular
JavaScript object I would say hey object
dot property name what are any and alert
object up property minute I would do
something like this I would say you know
of our foo equals some object and then I
would say alert Fuu dot bar this should
access the bar property on foo yeah in
backbone you don't do it this way you
say foo equals new you know user where
user is a backbone model and I'll pass
in some some parameter let's say that
bar is equal to 3 now all the sudden I
can't access food on bar who is no
longer a vanilla JavaScript object
instead I'm forced to interact with it
he again as he said it so I'm going to
call the get function and I would pass
in the string bar and back when we do
the work of that look up for me
but Marcus isn't that really annoying
yes it
later and we want to set food bar or
rather whose bar absolute and I'd say
food upset bar to be seven this is a big
big big problem there's a lot of reasons
this is a problem some of them some of
the reasons involved the fact that a
lotta libraries were written in history
that rely on vanilla property access the
backbone does not play by those rules in
part because javascript does not offer
enough features for Beckham to do a
backbone promises
using vanilla property access so the
what what they've chosen to do is is
require that users of the backbone
library call bucket and offset and every
time they want an accent even though mom
are there any questions about getters
and setters as they relate to moms yeah
is there any way not to use get a
success the only thing and you
definitely shouldn't do this the only
thing you could do is ignore the
existence of the document offset and
just start tacking properties onto the
model object itself the problem is you
will be skirting around all of the
framework that you downloaded and
meticulously install and like used in
your project and you won't have any
other features the backbone promises so
perhaps a more accurate answer is no
there's no way around it but technically
you can just ignore them I'm so glad you
asked I was going to I was going to
insist that someone asked a question
until that came up why did they
introduce getters and setters so well
that change notifications in a word
order words it's changed notification
JavaScript doesn't provide an API
dumpster objects do not provide any
interface that allows you to listen for
changes to a llama or to an optical at
least up until very recently and since
it's not cross-platform yet we can't
really rely so since backbone is
attempting to facilitate an automatic
relationship between models and views to
keep views in sync with models so that
you don't have to maintain consistency
yourself you want to just interact with
your models and trust them the
transformation up to the view is working
on its own that's the whole that's the
whole value crop of backbone since uh
since backbone says hey play by our
rules and you won't have to think so
hard about about the consistency of your
view and maintaining its you know
pairing with the
that is reflected in your model system
in fact one's going to make that promise
it needs to know when the model changes
so it encloses this constraint it turns
out their rabbit leg rubber solutions to
this problem but they're not very
intuitive but the other frameworks kind
of started using them they have the
drawbacks if you if you want the
simplest framework backbone is a good
choice because it makes a lot of dead
simple choices if you want the simplest
application after having used the
framework probably pick something else
is backlinks a very complicated
applications if that makes sense it
offers so little and the ways that it
offers you things can be unintuitive or
even misleading you only want to use it
on projects that are the scale of
support that are supported by the week
that said a lot of high scale websites
are using backbone them making it do
backflips for their for their own
purposes I certainly don't mean to
disparage the backbone community or the
preeminent designers but they were
designing for a very specific design
intent of a very specific use case they
did not want to see their framework get
overly complicated on the inside and as
a result a lot of the choices we have to
make as developers within the backbone
framework can be overwhelmed at times
cool
elections as I mentioned before our
collections are basically models they're
basically arrayed like models or they
can be thought of as such they follow a
lot of the same rules conceptually but
they lacked some of the infrastructure
that you would hope for from a model for
example they don't have getters and
setters
they have index accessors you can get at
set different values from the middle or
the end of the beginning of the sequence
you were truly the orderly sequence
values that the collected stories but
you don't get not get enough set on
arbitrary keys this can be problematic
if you have for example a playlist and
the playlist is supposed to contain many
songs but the playlist also has some
attributes like title and owner you
won't get done you won't have access to
get enough set such that you can sort of
maintain those things over time you
instead have to do some lengthy
collection inside a model type type
solution are there any questions about
collections so far
- all alright where the attendees start
free whoa
time flies lockets there all right we're
on the last slide special input
parameters when you are defining a you
or collection or model class so in the
process of defining the view model a
view amount or flexing this word has
meaning as we explore when you are
defining a vehicle of view class or when
you're defining a collection class the
word model has meaning every view has a
model because a view is a projection of
some collection of truth a profile that
did is a projection of the truth about a
user so if you're ten of you're defining
a view class you want to ask yourself
what model powers this class say mister
of a collector a collection is a
collection of some type of thing you
want to specify what type of thing it's
supposed to be a collection when you're
defining a view class you want to
specify what should happen when the user
interacts with that view this is as
closest backbone gets to have it in
controller user input will come in the
form of clicked and general targeting
activity on some Dom node and that Dom
node is probably represented by a view
object right so they're interacting with
that profile widget that is a projection
of
user object you want a way of specifying
all of the reactions that should happen
for all of those types of events it's
called the events hacks because when
defining a new class you will
you will of course have initialize as
usual but you may also have an event at
events is going to be things like flick
dot user or like dot you know follow
when people click on the follow button
of the user profile you want this
function to run
it's just a mapping of not interrupt
the code you type here is whatever you
expect to happen when the user clicks
the button with class follow-on so
system mapping from the event
specification the event specifier
including the target that is to be
interacted with to functionality that
you want to happen there are two
conventions that are rather interesting
for view classes you're going to specify
the render operation this is does that's
the keyword per se it's just everybody
calls for every view there's some way of
transforming the bottle into a glob of
HTML or into a Dom node object whatever
you're rendering to your render function
does the work of checking out the model
right every view has one Associated
model check it out the model and and
projecting it into whatever HTML or Dom
node the render operation is supposed to
produce cut out to you whether you've
done those or HTML backbone doesn't
really prescribe anything in that regard
sometimes your render operation is going
to rely on the template if that's the
case you'll probably store in a template
so just to be clear those would show up
here
and this is makes the function available
so that I can call you know my profile
view object dot render and get the
rendered the currently updated rendered
version open any questions about render
a template yeah just have a question
about the models and viewers in general
is a few always tied to a single model
only yes okay so if you wanted to
display multiple models on a page to
need multiple views so the question is
is they view always tethered to one
model only and my answer is basically
yes there are some exceptions to this
the first is your view can be a view of
a collection in which case you would
ceiling if it was like a view of the
tweet stream you would you would you
would map to a collection that
represents all of the tweets in that
stream but really it's pointing at one
model which is to say a collection seems
like an almost along the other way in
which this is not quite true is you will
sometimes build objects model object
whose sole job is to encapsulate
together all the things needed to render
a given view ideally you don't have to
consider the view while you're designing
your model architecture but in practice
that isn't always true sometimes you got
to say well we're going to make this
kind of rendering
back home paradigm I'm gonna have the
structure my model differently than I
would probably like to just to make sure
that the view has accident all right
stuff it is an anti-pattern and this is
this is sort of extracurricular
recommendation for me about about MVC is
stuff related to backbone that's
universal
it is an anti-pattern it bad bad bad
idea to allow any of you to get access
to models other than whatever model it's
directly projection by doing so you open
the floodgates to all of the basically
of you having being influenced by any
code anywhere you're in your system if
you should never have knowledge of more
models than the one it's projecting and
it should never have knowledge of any
views around it other than its direct
children this up something as a child
view the only case where you should know
about another
no the promoter was couldn't we just say
that but enforces that a new does not
have access to anything but its own
single model and the fact is it does not
it is extremely easy for you the
developer to save references to models
all over the place willy-nilly and then
make your views go reference those those
those other models now the framework
makes it easy to get access to exactly
one column but it's it's it's almost as
easy to circumvent the thing to
facilitate great vessel so the framework
kind of requires you to more or less
pollute the model if there's if you need
to incorporate some things that you want
to render the Bugis Street particularly
not strictly part of your so the
question is if I have a view that needs
to project more than just a single model
is the backbone is the backbone Frank
we're basically requiring me to serve to
two to four to forego the assurances of
this wonderful rule about don't let the
view talk to more models at a tone and
in fact it's not the backbone framework
of its imposing that problem it's the
nature of the example you're giving
example you're giving some presupposes
that there's a projection of more than
one model and I would claim that the
best solution of those cases is to get
your view to project some higher order
model than encompasses everything I for
example write very few applications that
don't have an app model I believe it's
the case that the business logic the
model logic generally requires us to to
have a model of the application that the
user is experiencing that is projected
by the app view this is an architectural
that has some controversy around it but
intend to solve most of the problems
that you're talking about and although I
find it a very difficult argument to
make
I currently believe it's the best
architecture for most circumstances
alright how does the render button get
ahold of the model whenever you
instantiate when whenever you
instantiate a view I don't have it
listed here unfortunately when the
staging of you need to specify the model
I think I accidentally put it up here
under defining the viewer collection
class which would have a different
meaning instantiating a view you specify
what model object what model instance
you want that view to project and then
the render function is just going to ask
the view hey what what are we talking
about again what table are we associated
with when you instantiate a view
there will be an element created for you
at Dom element and that Dom element is
the thing that goes on the page
basically backbone views are to stuff
downloads
they are fancy versions of jQuery
objects which are themselves fancy
versions of dominance right the jQuery
object
fundamentally attempts to abstract over
the complexity of a dominant or flexing
Dom node
that's not what this situation entails a
jQuery object that contains one Dom node
is just a better API for interacting
with that dominant a backbone view is
basically an even richer API for
interacting with that jQuery object so
when you want to talk to that ops that
decree on it directly you specify you
talk about my new instance dot yeah or
my new instance top dollar deal where
yelling to make it down though and
dollar TL is the jQuery redundant when
you instantiate of you you can specify
what now I'm going to use but if you
don't what will be generated for you and
that's it that's all the lingo I have
seven minutes so I'm going to take
questions for a couple of them but if
you are wanting to come to the four
o'clock talk I recommend you take a
bathroom break and when I go right now
unless you're super riveted by the
answers to the questions that are about
to be asked but the next lecture is is
all about the secrets and lies of
JavaScript classes it'll be the
culmination of all the work we've been
doing in all of the previous
fundamentals of lectures yeah
does it mean that uh
yes backbone usually depends on jQuery I
think backbone does it depend on it
outright or does it have a motive the
but you have to have a dollar yeah you
know some Domino aquarium provider yeah
so you need you need some Dominic
elation library probably gentler what
would be a scenario where you want to
use backbone for any of the other you
know maybe more full-featured frameworks
like personally call me at the question
was when would you choose to use
backbone over other frameworks call the
intervention I am dissatisfied with all
the framework solution citizen offered
for awhile
unfortunately JavaScript is limited
enough that may all represent different
compromises and so the question really
becomes when will I be forced to use one
or other of these compromises I think
you'll be forced to use backbone when
using a heavier framework is impractical
frameworks like angular and ember
full-featured though they maybe have a
lot of complexity to them so intuitive
how they work is difficult if you're
just starting right it will be an
imposition of other development backbone
backbone I would argue gets too
complicated to be worth it pretty
quickly but if it's a small app I think
the simplicity that it that is its
thriving tenant is actually valuable for
small enough ass that said I find the
duck get that set as well as some of the
this discord between its own features
like internal discord between its
features
I find that challenging enough to hack
around every time it pops up but frankly
just don't use the framework before much
but it's a great learning tool to learn
about like how soon framework function
how does a framework work what does the
framework doing and what's backbone not
doing for me today that's why I want
this other framework that's going to
make huge imposition on me and require
me to read tons of documentation but
it'll break less frequently because it's
not because it doesn't plan that in
Angela has planned ahead for wait what's
an area of the backbone have that code
runs into a wall of just unanticipated
complexity point three any other
backbone questions before we husband
asked for a quick summary on how extend
words it's as the parameter that takes
the hash does it only look for specific
parameters in there or does it just take
anything to find and tack it on to the
object the way angular
the how does not extend work there are
some special teams like initialize but
all the rest of them just go right on
the prototype every other property use
you pass becomes a property of prototype
in that class so much my question is
immediately would you be able to seal
the class by overwriting extend within a
lock function by seal do you mean not
extendable itself I mean so the question
is could you seal the class by
overriding extend for the Noah you can
seal it it as much as it would be
difficult to accidentally extend to that
class right but it would be trivial for
someone to circumvent your ceiling they
could just call extend up apply it's
stealing my other model that extend up
lie to that thing so as it's sort of
like bookmark to yourself to prevent
accidental misuse yeah you can do that
I'm actually just done of having to Noah
I would have to throw an error since you
apparently wanted to really that's more
disgrace by the backbone prevented you
from overwriting some of its own face
great question does backbone service
prevent you from doing things like
overrated not extend it cans for the
same reasons that it has not set it up
yet it has no way of knowing when you're
acting this property so unless it's
checking them on some schedule older
sounds pretty inconvenient to the
framework to do just to make sure
the question is is backbone more than BC
of Mormon mvvm and that question was
prefaced by I'm often confused by the
distinction I guess I was saying I am
also confused by the distinction I
believe that the the concepts of MVC
are so fluid and so interpretable as
meaning very many different types of
things that to start proliferating the
number of classifications of MVC is
perhaps counterproductive but you might
have pick one
I think mvvm is perhaps better in this
case now that said like I think of media
itself is poorly on that I was actually
been asked what you thought that the
concept of praying and at modern - to
encompass maybe some other models that
need to be instead of the same talking
to you was kind of
yeah yes yes I actually so this is a
great class in minutes we're getting
sort of lofty above NBC which makes me
happy this is like one of my favorite
topics the fact that I advocate for a
view model I'm sorry for a yes a view
model does that seem to our site at half
miles given the fact that I've seen it
at the Cape for an app model does that
imply that I am in favor of mvvm either
form a club or quite generally I would
say that in fact having an app model
strikes me has a rather non-optional
aspect of ending than VC application its
optimum as much as you can avoid it but
you can also avoid ever having
collections in any application then you
can just hack around it using other
techniques for solving the problem of
ordered lists of things it would be
better if you just choose to have a
actual order or a light sequence of
things as opposed to giving everything a
unique random name and then keeping
those a linked list I don't know what
you can do to hack around that I believe
that the app model is so important to
any MVC or mvvm application that to try
and write an application without it is
to doom yourself to a lot of aimless
academic questions about what is MVC
really and how do I classify this
behavior does it is it business logic
which I still never heard a definition
for I think there are a lot of spurious
questions out there and they are links
to the fact that people feel
uncomfortable defining a app do you
consider the app model more part of the
or see the F I would say that the app
model is very much a an aspect of the
model generally and since we're on the
topic on the bank might my defense for
it
when a user uses an application they
interact with a lot of state that we
wouldn't consider sort of pristine and
abstract like which users are following
which users and how old is this one user
these are things that we can all agree
are so so pristinely you know blessed
with model enos that no one there's no
controversy about whether that is state
that the user cares about having
consistently managed in some database
summer we become uncomfortable when we
talk about state that seems to be best
represented by the abusive sin itself so
for example when a pop-up box is open or
not and whether or not that pop-up box
has been dismissed these are these are
states that the user can get themselves
into as a result of navigating your
application that many people want to
watch you call view state and what I
call that the logical view state or
something and I think this is a
contradiction in terms
as soon as you build an app we're
logging in on another computer later
should show you the same pop up as you
were seeing before you suddenly discover
that that state was very important to
your user and you've promoted out of
this link some power class of state
where when you click view state and you
say this is actually not as often you
know abstraction state these to you I've
been at several companies that have
built notification trackers special
systems that keep track of whether or
not a user offenses acknowledge a
certain message everyone in the system
must see we are upgrading our system
day or we changed our trips and
conditions and they build these really
different infrastructures to support
this brand-new animal if we were to
accept that that state itself like all
state is actually just related to
perhaps a narrowly scoped user
experience but it's related to the truth
of it of what a user knows about the
world we wouldn't have a lot of these
philosophical complaints about the
differences between MVC and MVP mmm
okay I think I'm a few minutes over I've
been talking them up my voice billiards
so I'm thinking of taking like a two
minute break its water maybe you guys
need it as well it's like a two-minute
break in the middle start our final
installation of the fundamentals series